there there's always some weird [ __ ] in
art school did you go to what school did
you go to you go to an ivy league thing
like nah i just went to cody did too no
no i went to a state school and is that
public knowledge by the way can i say
that yeah okay so one of those things i
didn't know they're like what what are
you smart exactly wow he deserves his
education that's weird
nah i just went to a state school
because uh i [ __ ] up a lot of my
college gra or my high school grades so
my options were really limited i went to
state school that was pretty easy to get
into but they had a good business
program and then like three years in i
was like i don't want to do this so i
dropped out for a bit i took up
programming and then as i was like doing
well with programming all my co-workers
were like dude just go finish like it's
not a big deal and so uh yeah i finished
so i have a business degree but no i
didn't go to art school i i debated
dropping out and going to art school but
they're all so goddamn expensive yeah
it's such a waste of money yeah it's
crazy
not to
try to get into the politics of college
and stuff that's a big life choice when
you're 18.
you can buy it i think you're going to
say you're in favor
not to get all political but i think
college tuition should be higher yeah
exactly that's like when are they going
to raise it
i'm tired of people talking about how
like less they're paying i want to start
feeling better about my experience yeah
yeah raise that [ __ ] up yeah people
talking about loan forgiveness and [ __ ]
i'm like you know hey
those sins can't be cleansed today we
ain't forgiven nothing for a while you
know what i mean what the [ __ ] was i
even saying i had a stroke you brought
up something to me
i was like i just remembered like yeah
[ __ ] uh what is it great lakes borrow
loan service yeah i just remember
calling like i like wore flashbacks uh
the automated message asking you for
payment yeah or like a person just be
like hey how much can you pay yeah man
yeah i mean yeah and you're like damn
did i work at planet sub you know like i
nothing at the time i dropped out i was
down horrible i was like in a pretty bad
financial situation so i had like
collectors calling all the time
and i always say what was your best lie
my favorite thing was to just go hello
and then they would start screaming
that's typical okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
i love saying hello when i just want to
make sure that the audience knew that i
knew that was normal just to make sure
he like yeah so i start with the hello
curveball yeah go ahead they don't
expect exactly what they don't expect
the guy to be so cordial yeah oh my god
yeah well i guess that's probably pretty
normal too probably thinking that you're
just immediately going to be like [ __ ]
off yeah i disarm them i'm like hey yeah
and i let them chat me up nah i just
love to hang up on them in the middle of
them asking yeah so you owe that uh we
were wondering could you make it
damn yeah that's cold i mean at that
point in my life i'm like i have zero
dollars man i have negative money and
you are saving them time in the long run
i guess yeah i think i tried having a
person they're saying like what's the
least amount you could pay i think i was
like i think i quoted them like
they wanted me 500 bucks that's what i
was gonna say earlier was that when
you're 18 what a life decision mm-hmm
you can buy camel crushed cigarettes you
buy condoms and feel kind of weird about
it still yeah and then you can
sign up for hundreds of thousands of
dollars yeah yeah and see a rated our
movie well you could do that the year
before which is still kind of cool
but you're still new to it so you're
like could you do radar movies 17 yeah
oh here i thought it was eight i'm
pretty sure it was 18 at least in l.a
yeah i'm pretty i'm gonna stand by my
what i say it's a controversial opinion
yeah yeah you could definitely see it
right here i could go see 300 if i
wanted to yeah in the theater yeah i
could see a sex scene i could see people
die on camera but at 18 you could do all
that and have crippling debt mm-hmm and
smoke a cigarette yeah which is so much
cooler it was very cool yeah do you
remember him do you remember secured
credit cards i had a walmart credit card
get the [ __ ] out of here what was your
limit are you comfortable i literally
want to say maybe like 700 dollars
when i was younger i got a credit card
and it was just god it's such a piece of
[ __ ] just to buy a tv on black friday of
course
of course it took me like four years to
pay off yeah exactly i discounted tv
yeah that was that was rough was your
after you got your walmart card was it
ever below 700 or were you consistently
maxed out
i think i i i don't think i ever even
used it again i think i um yeah i think
i cut it and cut it after i was done
with it i bought it that day and i
thought i was like you know what [ __ ] it
okay cut it as if it was like that it
was making some kind of statement in
some sort of way but it took me you know
what like four years to pay off a tv oh
i'm sorry i thought you used another
credit card to get that tv you used the
walmart card i literally signed up for a
walmart card on black friday
okay
liberty missouri and they're like those
tvs are good in the back you know and
they're like guiding you through it so
you like you don't feel like a total
piece of [ __ ] you're like oh yeah i'm
just excited yeah it's a tv from last
year yeah it's like literally a [ __ ]
uh like a vizio
weird tv that's all bricky and [ __ ]
weighs like 700 pounds you don't even
know how the hell you're gonna get it
into your house
uh yeah they're like we can for an extra
fee and i'm like man i'm pushing the
limit as it is with this
with this credit card i'm like i really
got much my name i have like totino's
party pizza and some yoo-hoo yeah in my
cart and i'm like i mean i could give
this up that's only seven how much is
the delivery 50 bucks i'm like
yeah i'll throw in the back of my 93
toyota paseo and i'll head on home
and then it falls out the back halfway
home and you're just like oh yeah it'll
make it yeah yeah
you're like yeah it's pretty good well
there's like already so much things
wrong with the car you're like there's
probably this thing probably take one
more yeah
i had a sunroof that the latch didn't
work so you would drive down the highway
and be like
like that and then people would like
flash their lights at me and stuff and
i'd like pull over and they're like your
sunroof's go i'm like do you think i not
know that my sunroof what do you think
i'm doing in there like i totally can't
hear this thing [ __ ] smashing yeah
the top of my roof and stuff yeah so you
got the tv and you paid your [ __ ] 38
interest on it for four years that's
exactly right yeah yeah secure credit
cards are funny when they would like
you'd have to give them a certain amount
of dollars like that would be your limit
okay you want to put down a thousand
bucks and you give them that so when you
ran it up and you're like i can't pay it
they're like that's cool and they just
zero you out and close that [ __ ]
they're like thanks brother i don't
think i've ever heard of that it's like
an old school thing that they definitely
don't do anymore i i got one like right
before washington mutual got bought by
chase
and so i think they were just you know
doing the scummy as [ __ ] like yeah you
16 yeah we could [ __ ] it up
exactly yeah yeah let's get you on
something man
let's get you on let me let's put that
crap i want you to spoil yourself today
yeah go get a tv buy yourself something
pretty yeah yeah i had like i went like
this manic state did the same thing i
got a best buy credit card
and i [ __ ]
i just like walked in there after i'd
not i didn't sleep for like i don't like
three days or something i just went in
and i just
and just took like a camera a computer
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] and i like came
to
a few days later and i was like what the
[ __ ] have i done
i'm like nah it's cool like you bought
three gopros yeah as if you like you're
like what like who what kind of friend
group do i have yeah
we're going to utilize all these [ __ ]
gopros
ever just you know you just saw like on
the plastic wrapping it said like uh
it's like works in water
i'm not even buying an ocean yeah
i'm not even buying a pond so i'm just
standing in the shower and just yeah
record recording yourself and [ __ ] half
asleep in the morning
day 17
my manic state got a toshiba laptop that
has like 100 gigabytes of memory yeah
maxing it out immediately
yeah that was the funniest thing because
i used to work at best buy and i
remember people would get credit cards
to get
500 laptops
and they were pieces of [ __ ] and i'd
always want to like just like grab them
by the shoulders and be like
if you're taking credit out to get this
piece of [ __ ] laptop
don't do it i thought it was getting
romantic for a second oh you're like
grabbing my shoulders give them a kiss
yeah i love your frugal behavior
exactly you make all the wrong decisions
and i like that yeah exactly you're
somebody i think i could get behind
you